日本語アドバイス第9回へこのようなこの
ようなめっちゃむずい感じを日本人はどう
やってパソコンで呼んでいますか
aoe お知らせですこのようなめっちゃ
難しい漢字を使うのは
日本語能力を褒められたい外国人だけだ
から心配しなくていいっと漢字を覚える法
学習法を教えてくださいそうだなあこれも
説明するのがちょっと難しいんだけど
ちょっとやっ
行ってみます話してみます説明してみます
ね
ええ感じの漢字を勉強するときはその
音読みと訓読みを最初から両方とも
覚えようとするのではなくその感じが出て
くるエイ
看護を覚えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
思います一度も
感じいわゆる感じ勉強っていうのはやった
こともう一度もないんだよねでもたくさん
の単語を1個ずつこう覚えることによって
今たくさんのか感じの両方の読み方が
を知っているんだよね
漢字を勉強したわけじゃないんだけど単語
を勉強することによってそれが身についた
だからまあマットさんも多分同じ意見だと
思うんだけどたしかそうだったんだけど
漢字を勉強するのではなく単語を勉強する
理由これが一番効率がいいんじゃないかな
と思いますじゃあこれそれはやめた方が
いい点を持っている方はいると思うんだ
けど
まあ個人的な感想に過ぎないからまあ一つ
の勉強方法学習法っていうふうにへ覚えて
いただけたらと思っていますはと外はとか
の使い方がわかるんだけど友達には説明
できないどうしたらいいと思いますか
そうだな
説明できるように英語をもっと勉強した方
がいいと思います日本人がいない環境の中
でどう日本語を勉強したら良いと思います
か常に日本語を聞くことだからまあ僕が
よくやるのは常に進撃の巨人を聞くことで
エッチ進撃の巨人さっきそれはだめじゃん
って言ったじゃんさっきそれはダメだって
言ったじゃんでそうなんだけど
まあ僕と彼の場合は逆に日常的なアニメ
だったら日本語の勉強にはならないんだよ
ねもうそれに出てくる単語言葉はもう全部
知ってるから
でも神力の狂人とかだったら逆にこう
普段使わない単語がたくさん出てくるから
逆に勉強になる例えば一番新しいシーズン
の第1番温かな大一番
に塹壕っていう言葉が出てきたんだよね今
永劫今ちょっと忘れてるんだけど
そのピット pets
ちょインチパンチティ
多分大丈夫だと思うんだけどチェンジと
いう言葉
まあもちろん英語はしてたんだけど
今まではそれが出てくる本とか a
本気でこう暗記でエッグとかへ
出会ってなかったんだよねだから逆に進撃
の巨人っていう現実的じゃないアニメ
によってを使ってそれその使うことによっ
てその単語を覚えたでそういった単語逆
結構多いんだよね実は
あとは何だろうこう
まあ要塞とか
塹壕とかへ
走行
装甲列車の走行とか全部普通の会話の中で
会話とか普通の本とかの中でも絶対出てこ
ないから逆に上級レベルにもなると
そのようなアニメは実は使った方が効果的
という風に自分に言い聞かせていますここ
にうんエクササイズバイクがあるんだけど
エクサう運動しながら
進撃の巨人を見て
進撃の巨人の最終シーズン1番は最も
新しいシーズンに新しい単語が出てきた
ときはそれを
かいておぼえる
最近機のだったパターン覚えたのは
駆り出す駆り出すなんで俺たちはこの前線
に駆り出されてるなーってあのはるかが
春子がああいうんだよねでまぁ文脈によっ
てだいたいわかるんだけど一応その場でa
調べてああこういう意味なんだなっていう
ふうに今メモしているっていうかでそれが
もうたい不勉強に乗っている日本語の
アクセント
へ
なかなか
聞き取れないどうしたらいいと思いますか
アクセントが全く聞き取れない人だったら
勉強してもダメだって言うような人が
たまにいるんですよね3ヶ月勉強したした
のに未だに端と端の区別がつかないその
ような人たまにいるんですけど
の人だったらそのような人だったらどうし
たらいいかといいますと
それ以外のことを極めるのほうがいいん
じゃないかなと思いますっていうのは
アクセント勉強したいっていう気持ちがあ
るっていう事はできるだけ日本語を上達し
たいぱそこらへんの外国人土地なんだって
こう思われたいっていうか多分その気持ち
はちょっとあるんじゃないかなと思います
でもいくら時間がたってもわかんないって
いうことであれば
会えでもパッっといえばなんだけど
カタカナを
これ冗談に聞こえるだろうけど冗談じゃ
ないからカタカナを極めた方がいいんじゃ
ないかなと思いますカタカナをきれいに
書けるようになるとか
あのカタカナが綺麗に書ける外国人僕見た
ことないからね
あのカタカナが綺麗に書ける外国人だっ
たら多分相当なにこの何これこの人って
多分なると思うんだよねまあひらがな
ひらがなでもいいんだけどカタカナが遠く
に難しいから
感じでもう大体ごまかせるんだけど
カタカナをシンプルだから
ごまかせないんだよねもうシンプルである
故に
もうちょっとでもバランスが崩れてしまっ
たら下手だって下手だって丸んだけど
真面目にか誰かの何カ月かけて勉強すれば
たぶん逆逆にうまくこの人すごいてなると
思うんだよね日本語上手って言われたくな
いっていうか本当に日本語が上手だった
思われたいから思われたいから間違えるの
怖いっていう考え方をからどう
脱失脱出でいいのかな
したらいいと思いますか日本語のいい
ところは
順番たか気にしなくてもひっとんどの場合
は伝わります
から順番を気にしなくてもほとんどの場合
は伝わりますほとんどの場合は伝わります
よね日本語はだからまあ日本語そこまで
固くないんだって来た気づいたら少し自信
が持てるようになるんじゃないかなと思い
ます日本人の女性
がからの
返事が
返事が全然構内どうしたらいいと思います
かそうだなあこれちょっとムーン
あえて下手な日本語を使ったらどうですか
下手の日本語だったら多分もう絶対に
日本語上手って言われるから
その前提で作戦を立てたらどうですか
ん
me